>>> Ladies and gentlemen, would you please
welcome Jeff Sharkey.
[ Applause ]
>>Jeff Sharkey: Hi everyone, my name is Jeff.
I'm a software engineer on the Android team.
Today we're going to talk about doing more
with less.
And along the way, we're going to build an
app that's worth a billion dollars.
So where do we get started?
First, I think we all can agree that we want
to build a great user experience, an experience
that is fast when we are interacting with
the app in the foreground.
But also lightweight when we are running in
the background.
Really, this all comes down to resources.
Resources like CPU and memory and disk I/O.
On a mobile device, these resources are constrained
and they are shared amongst all the apps running
on the device.
If we want to build that great user experience
we just described, we're going to need to
work together.
So today as we build an app, I'll show you
how we can work together and how we can do
more with less.
So let's start by building a simple photo
gallery app made of two activities.
The activity on the left is a simple overview
of the photos the user has taken on the device.
There's a second activity on the right we
can drill down and see a detailed zoomed in
view of a specific photo.
So to build this today, we will be using the
media store contented divider on the Android
platform.
We can query the images.media.external.
We get back a list of the photos the user
has taken on the device.
One of the columns is the underscore ID column,
that.
With one of those IDs, we can use the thumbnails.get
thumbnail API to get a small scaled down version
of one of the photos the usuals has taken.
With the underscore ID we can build I/O a
full resolution of the photo to show the to
the user.
A moat today, I'll be digging through code
snippets.
I will be using the loader pattern to perform
that query and get that cursor.
That cursor comes back, I will hook it up
into a simple cursor adapter.
So each of the views that I will be showing
in the grid layout, grid view is going to
be an image view for each of the photos in
the list.
When I go to bind the view, I'm actually going
to kick off an async task to go load that
thumbnail on a background thread.
Because loading thumbnails, we are going to
go to disk.
Disk I/O can potentially block the main thread
of the application.
So hopefully everyone here is familiar with
async task and that pattern on the platform.
So here's the actual thumbnail async task,
what I'm doing.
The actual argument coming in is that photo
ID.
The bitmap is that small thumbnail.
Here in the middle in that background thread,
I'm using thumbnail, dot get thumbnail.
Load the bit map.
Pass it back to the main thread and assign
it into that image to show to the user.
Let's go ahead and take a look at this on
the device today.
Switch to the device.
So here's some photos have been taking around
the conference.
I can scroll back and forth.
Notice this scrolling is nice and smooth.
It stays smooth because we are doing that
disk I/O on a background thread.
But at the same time, if I scroll back and
forth, you will notice we end up loading the
photos multiple times, photos that we loaded
moments earlier, we are now actually having
to go to disk again.
We are kicking off a number of those thumbnail
async tasks in doing a bunch of duplicated
work.
We would like to avoid that, if possible.
One way to avoid that is caching.
There's a couple different ways of writing
caches on Android.
One way would be to use soft references.
Soft references don't give us much control
over when and how that memory is cleared by
the VM.
Instead, we are going to use a LRU cache.
Let's go back to the slides.
So an LRU cache, LRU stands for least recently
used.
A quick overview.
Another U cache is a bounded data structure,
it has a bounded size.
It keeps track of how recently items in the
cache -- how recently we have accessed them.
Thinking of our thumbnail example today, photos
that the user may have just recently looked
at are kept fresh in the cache near the front.
But thumbnails that maybe are off in the periphery
are closer toward the end of the cache.
Think as the cache needs to make more room,
it can evict the oldest items in the cache.
So Android actually offers a LRU cache implementation.
It's been in the platform since API level
12.
It's also in the support-v4 library.
You can use it on a wide range of devices.
Let's use it here today to build our thumbnail
cache.
LRU cache is a genericized class that takes
two types.
A key and a value.
For our purposes, we will map from a long
to a bitmap.
The long is the photo ID, the key of the cache.
Bitmap is if we have loaded one of the thumbnails
in the past.
One thing that's nice about LRU cache, it
offers us a size of method that we can override.
This gives us an opportunity to communicate
size of a specific item we are storing in
the cache, how much we would like it to count
against the maximum size or bounded size of
our cache.
In this case, I'm just going to return the
number of bytes that the bitmap object actually
represents in memory.
Just as an example, typical 320 by 240 bitmap
uncompressed in memory is about 307K, just
a ball park example.
You'd expect the two last methods here, just
a put and get you'd expect from a typical
caching API.
We can put items in.
We can attempt to see if an item is in the
cache with a get.
It will return null if it is cache miss, if
the item isn't in the cache.
Let's go ahead and hook this up into our application,
the one we have been writing today.
The first question that we need to answer,
how large do we make it cache?
It is a bounded size.
If we make the cache too small, it's not going
to be effective.
We will end up going to disk quite frequently
to load data if it's not in the cache.
But if we make our cache too large, we actually
risk exposing our application to an out-of-memory
error.
Whatever we are allocating inside out LRU
cache, we need to keep enough memory for the
other parts of our application like our activities
and layout that we are inflating.
So a good place to start for a cache size
is the get memory class on activity manager.
This returns a size in megabytes of how hard
of a memory limit we should impose in our
application to let the system work its best.
So some typical examples for this are about
48 megabytes on a Nexus S device and 64 megabytes
on a Galaxy Nexus.
The reason there is Galaxy Nexus has a gigabyte
of RAM so it has more space that applications
can take advantage of.
Okay, so we have -- in this case, I'm getting
the memory class, turning it into bytes, converting
from megabytes to bytes, and then I'm creating
the thumbnail cache.
A good place to start for the cache size is
dividing that memory class by 8.
So keep in mind that we have to keep enough
head room for the rest of our application
activities and layouts.
Dividing by 8 is a good starting point.
We will definitely want to look at our application
and tweak that value over time.
Keeping in mind those two trade-offs if we
make it too small or too large.
Now we have our cache, let's hook it up in
the two classes we were looking at earlier.
First in the async task, once we have load
the bitmap from the thumbnail API, we will
store it in the cache.
Then over in the cursor adapter, when we are
binding one of the views, we will check the
cache first just to see if we get a cache
hit, if that image has already been loaded
and it is still around for us to use.
If it is, we set it immediately and return
instantly.
If it is not in the cache, a cache miss, we
will need to kick off the async task to bootstrap
to load the thumbnail the first time.
Let's go ahead and take a peek at this on
the device.
Switch the device.
In this case today it's the same app and I
just have a menu item where I can enable the
cache.
The first thing you will notice is down in
the bottom right, I'm surfacing some statistics
about the cache, how effective it is.
These statistics are automatically tracked
by LRU cache, the class on the platform.
I'm surfacing here to see how effective our
cache is.
They are available, if you're interested,
for your own apps.
So now as we scroll through our list.
You can see that we still have to bootstrap.
We still have to go load the items.
Now as we scroll back and forth, those photos
are coming in instantly.
Scroll all the way down, back up, and through
the list.
A lot of them are in the cache and now they
are filling in perfectly.
Smooth UI, at the same time, I'm avoiding
the duplicated disk I/O. I'm taking advantage
of the room on the device to make my app faster.
We can see how much of a difference that's
actually making in the statistics.
The number of cache hits we have had down
in the bottom right there is 449.
So just in this quarterbacking example of
flinging back and forth in the list, we've
avoided having to go to disk and load data
over 400 times.
Caching is a great example of how we can do
more with less on the device.
But now you might ask the question, how much
memory are we actually using?
There's a great utility that can help us answer
this question.
So let's go back to the slides.
So today there's a great utility called procrank.
Let's use that on the device today.
Procrank is a list of all of the processes
that are running on the device sorted by how
much memory they are using.
In Linux there is many different ways of slicing
and dicing memory usage.
That's what these various columns are.
The number we are most interested in today
is USS, the unique set size of our application.
I will come back to that in a moment.
But first, Android at a high level, is a multitasking
operating system.
We want to enable users to quickly switch
between multiple applications.
Android does this by caching applications
in the background.
When you switch between an application, between
apps, it keeps your process running including
any memory that you have allocated.
But at the same time, if a user is in a foreground
app and that foreground app needs memory and
the system has used up all of the physical
memory on the device, the system needs to
come up with that memory somewhere.
So it begins looking through this list of
cached background applications, looking for
apps that can kill to reclaim that memory
to be used by the foreground process.
And that's where that USS metric comes into
play.
USS is a rough metric of the memory the system
would reclaim if it killed that process.
So if we look at this list, our application,
this gallery app that we have just written
today, now that's it's caching the data, it's
at the top of that list.
If some other process on the system comes
to the foreground and needs memory, our app
is actually first in line to be killed on
the device.
This will end up giving us a bad user experience.
If our app is killed and the user does want
to come back, we have to start from scratch.
We have to fork this IGOT.
We have to inflate our activities and any
layouts we were showing to the user.
And so, if possible, we would like to stay
cached.
And there's a way to do this.
Android offers -- it doesn't have to stay
this way.
We don't have to keep using all this memory.
Android offers a set of callbacks where we
can help release some of this memory back
to the system.
The first callback is on low memory.
Which has been around since 1.0 in the platform.
The downside of that is that method, that
callback is only called after all of the background
apps have already been killed on the device.
So if we are running in the background, it's
probably not very useful to us.
We would never receive this callback.
We would be killed.
So starting in Ice Cream Sandwich, in API
14, there is a new API, a new callback called
on trim memory which gives us a much more
granular view of the system state of how much
memory the system would like us to release
back.
And that level that it provides is the argument,
is a value between zero and a hundred indicating
how aggressively we should return memory back
to the system.
We will get into that a little bit more in
a second.
So both of these methods, both on memory and
on trim memory, are ready to override today
on activity fragment service content provider
and application.
If you find yourself outside of one of those
life cycles, you can also implement the interface
and call register component callbacks to use
if you are outside one of those life cycles.
So let's actually hook this up in the app
we have been writing today.
We talked about how there's a trim level that
comes in between zero and a hundred.
There's actually a handful of values that
are well defined.
Trim memory complete, moderate, background,
and UI hidden.
Those have been defined in Ice Cream Sandwich,
in API 14.
Those are well defined.
We can check against those levels, check against
those constants, but we don't want to do a
direct equality check because new levels could
be introduced into the future.
Here in the code sample, we will check against
the most aggressive trim level that we are
interested in.
So in this code example, we are checking if
the level is greater than trim memory moderate
which has a value of 60 under the hood.
This trim memory moderate indicates that our
application is nearing the middle of the list
of cached back applications, so the user hasn't
interacted with our app in quite a while.
They are off doing some other tasks on their
device.
The user make come back to our app but probably
not.
So this -- we can use this as a good hint
to release the memory that we have been using
for our thumbnail cache.
That's what we are doing here.
We are going to the cache and calling evict
all which will return all of that memory.
Next we are checking for slightly lower level.
Trim memory background which has a value of
40.
This is a hint from the system that our application
is just entering the list of cached background
apps, so the user was using us recently and
they may have switched away to other tasks.
We are going to use this, this is a place
where the fact that we are using a LRU cache
becomes valuable.
So remember earlier that LRU cache keeps track
of which items we've used recently and also
which ones are the oldest items in the cache.
So we can use the trim to size method to actually
evict or release the memory for the oldest
half of the items in our cache.
So if the user does decide to come back to
our application, we still have some of the
photos around the area the user was just looking
so it's fast and responsive there.
Photos that are further off in the periphery,
we have been able to release the memory back
to the system.
Just a side note, trim to size is actually
a private method on that LRU cache class,
but you can make a copy of the class and make
it public if you need to use it.
Another thing to note is that these callbacks
are purely advisory.
No guarantee that the system will call them.
In fact, if the system is under extreme memory
pressure, it may end up killing our application
before it has a chance to deliver the callbacks.
But if we release memory through these callbacks,
the system may be able to keep our app cached
longer, which is a better user experience.
We are able to launch our app faster if the
use does come back.
All right, so now our app, we have our gallery
app, it's running fast.
We're caching items, releasing some of the
memory back to the system.
So let's go ahead and add another feature.
Let's add the ability to star photos.
He can we can doing this using an action mode,
something introduced in Honeycomb.
Set choice mode, choice mode multiple modal.
When we do that, when the user long presses
on one of the photos in the list, the action
ball will be swapped and replaced with an
action mode where the user can select very
various items, various photos from the list
and then apply an action to them, like starring
or unstarring them.
One thing I want to look at today is conceptually
how that set of items is represented.
The items, photos the user selected.
So conceptually it's a map from an int to
a Boolean, where int is the position of the
photo of the list and Boolean is an indication
of whether the user has selected the item
or not.
We could sort this as a hash map from an integer
to a Boolean, but instead gridview and listview
on the platform return these values as a sparse
Boolean array which is an Android specific
data structure.
The reason for this is Autoboxing.
Autoboxing is a language feature which transparently
converts from primitives, like int into instances
of objects like java.lang.integer.
Autoboxing is powerful because it allows us
to mix primitives with genericized data structures
like hash map but it comes at a cost.
Each of those box perimeters, java.lang.integer
that we are forced to allocate, adds load
to the garbage collector on the system.
It's an actual object allocation.
Sometimes Autoboxing can sneak in if we are
not careful, if we are not aware of it.
So here's two code snippets.
The one at the top, we are actually looping
from zero to a hundred and adding up the total
of the numbers in side.
This actually allocates zero objects because
it is working with primitives the whole time.
But just that one simple change from int to
integer, that same loop that produces the
same resulting output value ends up allocating
over 96 objects.
The reason for that is that at each point
in the loop, we end up having to unbox that
total value, add to the primitive, current
I, and then rebox it back into total.
So this is where using Autoboxing like this
can add overhead to your app.
This is where sparse Boolean array comes into
play.
Sparse Boolean array allows us to map between
primitives while still avoiding that overhead
that comes with Autoboxing.
So here's an example at storing a hundred
key value pairs in various data structures.
The first one at the top is the one that we
were just looking at, mapping from an integer
to a Boolean.
If we stored that is a hash map, we end up
allocating over 200 objects under the hood.
This is because hash map internally allocates
a hash map entry for each pair that we are
storing.
But if we were to store that same data, the
same hundred key value pairs, in a sparse
Boolean array it takes many fewer objects.
In fact, the majority of the data is stored
in int array and Boolean array.
Which, from the perspective of the garbage
collector, are just a single object.
There are many other places -- data structures.
If you find yourself using one of these data
structures on the left that's mixing generics
and primitives, try looking at one of the
Android utilities instead.
It offers the same functionality but is much
lighter weight if you are looking to store
that data.
Okay, so now we have our set of stored photos
that the user is interested in.
Let's go persist it.
Let's use SQLite.
SQLite is powerful because changes that we
make are ACID.
Atomic, consistent, isolated and durable.
The selected photo IDs, for each of them we
are putting that ID and the start value into
content values.
Then we are going to be calling SQLite database,
then insert.
This code works.
It successful stores the data.
But dp.insert in this example guaranties,
makes those guaranties, those ACID guaranties
each time we call insert.
This overhead, the overhead of making those
guaranties, can add up very quickly.
So instead we can manage that overhead ourselves
by wrapping those mutations, those changes
inside of a transaction.
So it's the same core code here, the same
four loop, but before we call into that, we
are calling a begin transaction.
We are opening a single atomic transaction,
performing those mutations, then setting our
transaction successful and then ending it.
This ends up having a big impact.
So here's an example along the X axis of storing
a number of those values.
So from 20, 30, up to 100 different values
increase along the X axis.
Along the Y axis, we are looking at the actual
number of bytes that we ended up writing out
to disk under the hood to actually persist
that data.
So with the original code that we were looking
at, we can quickly see that that overhead
climbs up and to the right.
Because of that overhead, with each of the
DB inserts, we are making the ACID guaranties.
By wrapping, we reducing a lot of that overhead
because we are performing it as a single atomic
transaction.
Then you might ask the question, why not wrap
all of my mutations inside one big giant transaction?
This probably isn't a great idea either.
The reason is, in SQLite, be default transactions
are exclusive.
While someone is holding a transaction on
the database, no one else can read or write
to that database.
This is particularly visible if you have something
like a sync adapter in a background thread
that's syncing data down from the web and
you also have UI that you are showing to the
user, showing data to the user.
The UI may want to query and update data to
show to the user, but it may end getting stuck
situating for a transaction from the sync
adapter to finish.
So we can solve this.
We can solve this by inserting yield points
into our transaction.
So here's example of this.
We're doing our db.insert that we have been
using during the last couple examples, but
now we are inserting this method yield if
contended safely.
What this does, when we call into it, if the
database is contended, if someone else is
interested in performing a read or write on
the database, when we call in here, it will
end our current transaction that we are executing,
letting that other query, that other read
or write, proceed.
Then when that's finished, it will begin another
transaction before returning control back
into our loop.
The nice thing is, if the database isn't contended,
it will just return quickly.
We will still be able to perform a lot of
our data changes inside of a single transaction
if there's no one else waiting on the database.
But if there is, now we have an opportunity.
We're still using a transaction to apply the
changes quickly, but we are also -- our UI
can now be more responsive instead of potentially
showing a loading spinner for several seconds,
where those queries can come in and read out
some of the data to show to the user.
Cool.
So now I have my gallery app.
It's fast.
I'm starring photos to show to the user.
I don't know, but I have been taking these
photos around the conference and they are
just a little boring.
I guess if I had a way to make them more interesting.
Maybe if I had a SLR camera with some color
filters, I could spice things up a little
bit.
But carrying around equipment like this can
potentially get a little unwieldy, a little
heavy to carry.
So I guess we could write some code to do
it.
So if we are going to be writing image processing
code on Android, we want to make sure it is
fast and efficient so we are not wasting resources.
There's a couple different ways of writing
fast code on Android.
One option would be to use the NDK.
There's another way to write C code called
Renderscript.
That's what we will use today.
First, before I jump in, I will talk at a
high level about three benefits that Renderscript
offers us, three ways it let's us do more
with less.
So first, Renderscript automatically scales
to whatever hardware we are running on top
of.
Renderscript does this by taking our input,
which could be a bitmap, and splitting it
into small pieces likes pixels and then running
code on each of those pieces.
So in this example, if I have a photo up here
on the left, it's going to split up into pixels
and run an algorithm on each of those pixels.
Because it splits the work into pieces, Renderscript
can parallelize this work by creating a separate
worker thread for the CPU core in the device.
And it targets all architectures, including
ARM, X86, MIPS, and beyond.
And Renderscript does this by splitting compilation
into two stages.
First, it compiles our Renderscript code,
our effect.rs file in this example, into an
intermediate bit code.
Then it packages that bit code inside of our
APK.
Then when the app is installed on the device,
a second backend compiler takes the bit code
and compiles it into optimized native code
for whatever architecture and optimizations
that device may have.
Finally, Renderscript generates JNI glue code
for us.
If you've written code with the NDK in the
past, you've probably had to maintain JNI
glue code to jump between Dalvik down into
your native code.
But Renderscript generates a Java class and
methods to represent your script making it
easier to jump between those two worlds.
So let's dig into an example today.
Let's say we want to build a simple duo tone
style color effect.
Here's an example starting in the top left
with a single pixel.
Maybe that's like a red, a lighter red.
The first thing we will do is take the intensity
or the brightness of that color.
This gives us a lighter gray.
We're going to use that to map on to a gradiant,
a color gradiant between two values.
So between two values.
In this case, if the brightness of the -- intensity
of the color is darker, it will pick more
of the greenish or bluish value.
But if the color is brighter, it will pick
more toward the yellow.
And in this case, this color ended up giving
this greenish value.
And then we will combine together, mix together
those two values so we make the original red
with our green and this gives us more of this
olive color as an output.
So let's go ahead and write this code to make
it work.
So here's some Renderscript code.
We are defining a handful of pragmas to talk
with Renderscript to define what we are looking
to do.
The next thing, we are defining a constant
that we will look at in at in a moment.
The thing I want to focus on first is this
root method where we are defining it.
The root method takes two arguments.
Input pixel and an output pixel.
The data types of these arguments is, in this
case, an UR4, which is a vector type of four
unsigned characters similar to a byte.
You can think of this as four bytes in a single
type.
And bytes, in this case the four bytes are
the four color channels.
Alpha, red, green, and blue.
The first thing we do is convert incoming
pixel into a float four.
This is another vector type representing four
floating type numbers.
The next thing we will do, we will take the
dot product of that with another static float
four that we have outside of our method, a
global.
We take the dot product between those two
values, it's going to give us the intensity
or the brightness of that pixel.
I'll divide to give us a range between zero
and one.
So next I'm going to add a couple global variables.
Dark color, light coloring and strength.
Dark color and light color are float fours
that represent the two ends of the gradient
that we were looking at.
Finally, strength, which is going to indicate
how strong we want the effect to be.
So if we have a strength -- we will see how
to use that in a moment.
The next thing down in our root method that
we will add, we are going to use a method
called mix.
So Renderscript offers us a library of methods
that are useful for performing mathematics.
There's mix.
There's also other trig functions you might
be used to like sign and co-sign.
But we will use mix today because that offers
us the ability to map between the dark color
and light color.
So you will mix between dark and light using
intensity as the key so that if our value
is zero, it will pick dark color and so on
along that spectrum.
This is going to give us a tone color.
We are going to multiply that by intensity
will return some of the original brightness
to the current pixel we are working on.
We will use the red and final toned color
along a gradiant.
We will use strength as our value.
So if our strength is zero, we will use the
original input untouched.
If it's one, we will use completely the tone
color.
We will convert that back into UR4.
That's our return value from this method.
This is all in C.
Let's jump over to Java and hook this up.
Under the hood, it's creating a two-dimensional
allocation of uchar4s to represent our bitmap,
and then it's copying that data from the info
bitmap into the allocation.
And, finally, I'm using allocation created
type to make a mirrored output allocation
which we're going to use for the output of
our effect when we're done and we want to
show it to the user.
Okay, let's actually hook up the effect.
So remember a couple of slides ago I talked
about how renderscript generates GNI glue
code for us.
So when we defined our effect.rs file in the
SDK, and we compiled, it generated a Java
class called scriptc_effect which we can instantiate
and use over here in Dalvik.
So that's what I'm doing at the top.
I instantiate that script, and it also automatically
created a handful of those methods, that said
dark color, light color and strength, and
I'm able to call those nice and fast.
And finally, I'm calling script.foreachroot.
And this is what is going to take our input
allocation, our two-dimensional bitmap, split
it up into those small pieces and run our
root method on each of those small pieces,
on each of those pixels.
Finally, I'm going to copy the allocation
back from renderscript into Java -- or into
Dalvik and then show that bitmap in an image
view.
So let's take a peek at this on the device.
Switch to the device.
So here's the gallery map that we were using.
Let's go ahead and pick a photo.
Let's say one from the after hours last night.
So I can go apply the duotone effect.
So here's that strength, and as I drag back
and forth, it's updating that global variable
and pushing it down into renderscript and
then kicking off a for each, so each time
I'm changing the value.
So if I pull the strength all the way to the
top, now I'm picking along the side of -- I'm
picking along -- just applying the duotone
color effect, I'm not using any of the original
colors and then when I pull it all the way
down using all the original pixels, so if
I crank it up I can change like the dark hue
down to like red, or maybe I want something
like green, light hue, maybe like red, let
me find a sweet spot right in the middle.
Cool.
Now my photos are looking a whole lot better.
And I'm doing a great job with renderscript
of being able to apply them in a couple different
ways.
So let's jump back to the slides.
So remember earlier I mentioned there were
some benefits that renderscript offered us.
But really we've only scratched the surface.
Today in our root method, we only looked at
a single pixel at a time.
But in reality, we had access to the full
allocation, the full allocation in each of
the -- each time we were running through the
root method.
So this could enable us to write effects maybe
like a blur effect where we needed to look
at neighboring pixels or like an image filter
or like an image detection or a feature detection
algorithm.
Another thing to note is that allocations
are much richer than just -- today we just
looked at using a 2-D allocation of uchar4s
which represent bitmaps, but there are many
other types of allocations we can create.
For example, a one-dimensional allocation
of floats which can represent float audio
data.
So jumping back to those original things that
I mentioned, so renderscript allows us to
scale automatically to the hardware we're
running on top of.
So here's an example of how long it takes
to process a five-megapixel image, so identical
image on various hardware.
On the Nexus S it takes about 1200 milliseconds.
On Galaxy Nexus, which is a dual core device,
to process that same image, it only takes
400 milliseconds.
And the reason for this is under the hood,
renderscript is creating those two worker
threads, one for each of the cores on the
device and it's splitting up that work equally
for us.
So this is with the same code.
We didn't make any code changes and it's scaling
it to the hardware we're running on top of.
And also on the Nexus 7 that we announced
yesterday which is a quad core device, it
runs even faster, 240 milliseconds.
And again, because it's creating four of those
worker threads in the background and there
were no code changes on our part.
So today, on most of Android devices we're
just scaling on the CPU, but renderscript
is designed in such a way that we can scale
and run computations like this on the GPU
in the future.
Another thing, like I mentioned earlier, is
renderscript targets all architectures including
SMID style optimizations, so if you're familiar
with Neon on ARM or the SSE family of instructions
on x86, renderscript automatically emits these
optimize instructions when they're available.
If we had written this code with the NDK,
we would have had to write separate versions
of our algorithms with separate compiler intrinsics
with each of those instruction sets, but because
we wrote it with renderscript, we wrote our
algorithm once and that back-end compiler
took care of emitting those optimize instructions
for us.
Finally, renderscript isn't designed to replace
the NDK on the device.
It doesn't offer access to bionic libc, for
example, but renderscript is really designed
to be best at compute-intensive work and that's
what we used it for today in our example.
So renderscript is a great example of doing
more with less.
We've been able to scale automatically to
the hardware we're running on top of and to
use optimized instructions with much less
coding work on our part.
Okay, so we have this visual effect.
Let's say we want to apply it automatically,
and we can do this on Android.
There's a new powerful broadcast intent that
was introduced in API 14 that kicked off that
the system sends whenever a new photo is taken.
It's the new picture in 10.
So here in our Android manifest, we can listen
for it using a photo receiver and that's the
top definition here.
And then down below is the Java code corresponding
to that where we define our broadcast receiver.
And when we receive the broadcast we will
check to see -- we'll check a user setting.
If the user has enabled or disabled this effect.
If they want it applied, if we want the duotone
effect that we just applied automatically,
then we're going to go ahead and kick off
that work in an intent service.
The reason is if we did it right here in this
broadcast receiver, we would potentially expose
our app to an ANR, and because we're going
to do that disk I/O and the compute-intensive
work, we can to kick that off into an intent
service.
So this code works.
This gets the job done, it works.
But the down side is if the user has never
enabled this feature in our app, this system
is still going to wake us up, it will still
deliver the broadcast.
And we'll run our code, we'll come in and
check that play, and if it's disabled we're
just going to return.
So we're actually wasting system resources.
The system is waking us up and we're not doing
anything, we're just returning.
But it doesn't have to stay this way.
So there's a great way that we can use -- there's
a great API we can use on package manager
called set component enabled setting.
And we can use that today to turn on and off
our broadcast receiver dynamically.
So the one change we're going to make at the
top in our manifest is we're going to make
our broadcast receiver disabled by default.
So we can use that with the unable equal to
false flag here.
Then later, at runtime, when the user is interacting
with their app, we can dynamically -- we can
programmatically enable and disable that broadcast
receiver, so when the user turns on that feature
and wants the effect applied automatically,
we can turn it on and we begin receiving these
broadcasts in the background from the system.
And then if the user does decide to turn it
off, we can just as easily turn that broadcast
receiver back off to avoid the extra overhead.
So today we just used it for the new picture
broadcast, but there are many other broadcasts
that are maybe more interesting.
And it's especially important for common broadcasts
across the system, like connectivity change
or package added.
So say, for example, today in our app, if
we had written a photo upload queue, we were
uploading photos to the cloud that the user
had selected, if that queue is empty and we
listen for the connectivity chain event, our
app would be woken up and we wouldn't have
anything to do, our queue would be empty.
So that would be a great opportunity for us
to use this API, to turn off our broadcast
receiver when we don't have any work to do,
when there's no work pending.
Cool.
So today we talked about -- just a summary
of what we talked about, we built a gallery
app, we made
It fast by using caching.
Then we listened to trim callbacks to reduce
our memory usage, returned it back to the
system, to keep the system running nice and
smooth.
Then we looked at the overhead of autoboxing
and how we can avoid it using utilities like
sparse Boolean array.
Then we looked at SQLite and transactions
and how they can help us save disk I/Os, we're
saving to disk, persisting date.
Then we looked at using renderscript as a
great way of writing visual effects that scale
automatically to the hardware we're running
on top of with less coding work on our part.
And then finally we looked at broadcast receivers
and using them efficiently to enable powerful
effects without overhead on the system.
So today we built that user experience that
we really set up to build.
Our app is fast in the foreground, but our
app is also lightweight when it's in the background.
And because we work together with the system,
we built a great experience, not just for
our app, but for the entire system.
So hopefully today I've convinced you that
on Android you truly can do more with less.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>>Jeff Sharkey: So I think there's two mics,
if anyone has questions, there's two mics,
one in the front and the back of the room.
Feel free to jump up and ask questions.
If you're interested in the app that we built
today, the source code is available, there's
a link up there, if you're interested, it's
open sourced under Apache 2.0.
Yeah, go ahead in the front.
>>> Okay.
Hi.
Can you compare API shaders with renderscript
in terms of performance?
>>Jeff Sharkey: Sure.
So in this case shaders -- so there's two
parts to renderscript.
There's an open GL graphics part and then
there's also a compute part.
And I don't know if GL shaders, which part
they would fit under.
Do you know offhand?
>>> Well, depends on which processing so what
you have done can be done with GL shaders,
(indiscernible).
We also do GL shaders because they're enabled
in 2.3, but if renderscript can perform better
-- so is there value in like trying to support
renderscripts in Honeycomb + or just GL shaders?
>>Jeff Sharkey: That's a great question.
I actually don't know the answer off the top
of my head.
If you come up and catch me afterwards on
-- there's somebody around that probably we
can find an answer to your question.
>>> Thank you.
>>Jeff Sharkey: Thanks.
I'll take one from the back, if anyone's there,
or from the front, either way.
What's up?
>>> Hey.
Just want to ask about the autobox feature
that Java has.
I read on (indiscernible) that internally
an example in the, well, Oracle JVM, they
handle some sort of pool to prevent these
creational objects.
I was wondering, does this feature inside
Dalvik or --
>>Jeff Sharkey: So I can't speak to the details
of other VMs.
The one thing I know about -- so, for example,
integer in Dalvik, the implementation that's
there, it does actually create a handful,
a small pool, of integers for like small values,
like from negative 127 to like positive 127.
So it can share some of those values, but
not the entire range.
>>> Right.
So my second question would be like do you
manage to use the (indiscernible) for certain
things in order to prevent the creation of
serial objects but once you are going to use
a key and a hash mark you don't use it.
Like what's going on there?
Like, I mean, do you put it along as a key
-- you're creating several objects there or
also hash marks helped you in that way?
>>Jeff Sharkey: So you're talking if I use
different types of primitives?
>>> No, when you use, an example, a long as
a key in a hash map.
>>Jeff Sharkey: In the LRU cache?
>>> Yeah.
>>Jeff Sharkey: Right.
So LRU cache I still had that overhead of
auto boxing in that example.
We could write a version of LRU cache where
we changed the key just be whatever primitive
we needed.
But we would have to write a different class
for that.
Again, generics are powerful, but it's something
to be aware of.
So if we needed our LRU cache to be really
fast, we may write a specialized version that
avoids autoboxing.
>>> Thank you.
>>Jeff Sharkey: Yeah.
Next.
>>> I have a question on the LRU cache.
You said it started with API 12 and backward
compatible with the support core library.
What is the order of using the support library?
>>Jeff Sharkey: It's very -- it's small, so
-- the support library's going to pull in
Java -- like class files that -- into your
application.
It's a jar library that you attach on.
If you use something like Proguard, it can
strip out all of the other parts of support
V4 library that you're not using.
So that can help reduce the overhead.
It will just pull in the pieces that you're
not using.
>>> So we have an APK right now.
So you think it would be worthwhile, just
for the sake of the LRU cache, since we're
supporting versions 11 and up, just for the
sake of the LRU cache, to -- we don't the
support library right now -- to go ahead and
use the support library.
>>Jeff Sharkey: I would say go ahead and pull
it in if you also apply the Proguard because
it will help strip out the resources.
The worst case -- the source code is available,
it's licensed under Apache 2.0, so you could
copy the class into your app, just that single
class.
>>> And what's the backward compatibility
allowed for renderscript?
>>Jeff Sharkey: Sure.
So renderscript's -- I forgot to mention that.
It was originally introduced with Honeycomb,
so that's the API, the level that it was originally
introduced with.
>>> It has backward compatibility layer also
with it?
>>Jeff Sharkey: So it's API level 11 and up,
which is increasing, there's more devices,
like the devices we handed out today have
the higher API levels.
>>> Thank you.
>>Jeff Sharkey: Yeah.
Next?
>>> I have just two quick questions.
Actually, the follow-up on that, you said
it's available in a later version of the API,
but is it available from the support library?
>>Jeff Sharkey: No, renderscript isn't because
-- and part of it is that back-end compiler
that we saw, that needs to live on -- it needs
to be tailored for whatever device it's running
on.
So it really needs to be targeted to the device.
>>> The second quick question is: Is renderscript
capable of doing more complex image-processing
algorithms where you need to actually look
at neighboring pixels to compute your pixels?
>>Jeff Sharkey: Yes, yes.
So when you were in that root script today,
we just looked at a single pixel at a time.
We had full access to get neighboring pixels
or across the entire allocation so we had
access to all that data if we needed it.
>>> Thank you.
>>>Jeff Sharkey: Yeah.
Next.
>>> Hi.
Is there a different in performances or optimizations
between async task and async task loaders,
can we use the loaders instead of the async
loaders?
>>Jeff Sharkey: So the one thing that loaders
offer you is that if a result has been loaded
and the configuration changes, so like you
rotate the device, the loader will take care
of sending that across to the new activity.
If you did it with an async task, you would
have to manage and bring that along with it.
So an async task loader, it brings the power
of both worlds, you get the benefits of loaders
and the async task.
>>> Okay.
So there isn't any performance issues with
the loaders?
>>Jeff Sharkey: No, in fact, cursor loader,
if I remember correctly, actually extends
async task loader, so it's using it under
the hood.
>>> Thank you.
>>Jeff Sharkey: Yeah.
Next?
>>> Thank you very much.
I had a question about services.
You talked mostly about foreground end write
apps and best practices.
Is there a talk or have you given a talk about
how to use service -- make sure your service
is not abusing -- being a good citizen and
can use proc write for that?
>>Jeff Sharkey: So proc write is just going
to surface the memory usage of your process,
of your application.
And it doesn't offer any details into which
parts of your application are using that memory.
So one good strategy, you're talking about
services, intent services is one of my favorite
utilities because it helps manage and stop
-- as soon as you've finished processing the
intent, you've sent it, it takes care of shutting
down the service.
So that's probably one of the best practices
for services.
>>> No, but I mean when you write your own
service.
Let's say I'm listening to the, you know,
GPS, I have to write a service or a C2DM service
and I'm abusing the system.
How do I know, you know --
>>Jeff Sharkey: Oh, that's a great question.
So one way that you could potentially see
that is by looking -- so in the settings UI
and you go into apps, there's a list of running
applications on the device, so you see if
your service has been running for a long time
on the device.
So that can be a signal like if you don't
expect your service to be running.
In addition, like -- these are ways of tracking
down, I mean, you could also look at like
the battery stats on the device to see if
it's been using a lot of resources.
Are you asking more like strategies on how
to --
>>> Yeah, best practices for debugging services
or writing services, or do you give a talk
on that, too, or do you plan to?
>>Jeff Sharkey: I haven't -- I don't know
-- it sounds like a great topic.
I know there's probably a lot of interest.
Let's actually catch up offline.
Because, again, a lot of it is going to be
dependent on the specific application.
Some apps -- maybe it depends on what you're
doing in the service.
Next.
>>> My question relates to the service as
well.
I found a lot of apps, the user long run services,
yeah, like they use a lot of memory, right?
So right now there's -- I use CODM and also
I use right now the cloud service (indiscernible).
So actually consult a lot of problems, right?
I think that Android should forbid long run
service, like otherwise, you've only got 10
minutes, 10 minutes to do -- in the background.
>>Jeff Sharkey: I think it's one of those
things where if you actually truly have a
service running long, like we want to enable
the innovation, like somebody could have an
important use for a long-running service,
so I don't think we want to artificially --
>>> Special permission, it's like basically
destroying (indiscernible).
>>Jeff Sharkey: I mean, and that's where it
comes back, we give the UI to the user.
If they notice that a service they're not
happy with running a long time, we give the
user control.
>>> Now (indiscernible) memory.
So right now do we need to expressly call
recycle for bitmaps?
>>Jeff Sharkey: That's a great question.
The behavior internally of bitmaps has changed
slightly over API versions between Gingerbread.
The one thing to be careful of when you recycle
is that you need to make sure that it's not
actively being used in your UI anywhere, because
if you recycle it and it's still being used
--
>>> Destroyed.
>>Jeff Sharkey: Yeah.
So recycle under the hood, if I remember right,
the implementation released --
>>> Native.
>>Jeff Sharkey: Native allocation, right.
And so at some point we moved that allocation
to occur on the Dalvik keep.
So I don't know what recycle does in the newest
version.
It's a great question.
So if we meet up afterwards, we can look at
the source code and see what it does.
>>> Okay.
So for the screen rotation, right, should
we always allow system to handle the rotation
or just -- just handle the (indiscernible)
ourselves, that will avoid or create (indiscernible)?
>>Jeff Sharkey: That's a great question.
So you're talking about like the handles or
handles configurations or configuration changes
in the manifest?
>>> Yes.
>>Jeff Sharkey: My advice would be let the
system handle all those for you.
And the reason being like even if you tell
it that you want to handle orientation changes
on your own, so it may make your app fast,
but there's still the case where another configuration
could change and your app is still going to
be exposed and it may be slow in that case.
>>> If you have a lot of async tasks, you
have to manually handle those async tasks,
right?
>>Jeff Sharkey: Yeah, and that's part of why
the loader pattern was introduced because
that helps solve those issues.
It will keep running asynchronously.
And then if the result is delivered either
before or after the configuration change it
won't redo that work for you.
>>> What are they called again?
>>Jeff Sharkey: The loader pattern.
>>> Loader pattern.
>>Jeff Sharkey: Yeah.
So if you -- on activity you can do -- get
loader manager and there's several APIs on
there.
Yeah.
>>> Does the LRU cache handle data structures
that might change size while they're cached?
>>Jeff Sharkey: No, so the data structure
-- that's why we overrode the method today.
The only mechanism it has for counting it
against the maximum size is whatever we report.
So it's up to us to return how large the size
in the LRU cache is.
>>> Thank you.
>>Jeff Sharkey: Yeah.
Next?
>>> So the renderscript example will go out
like a pixel shader but I'm curious if it
can be used to do geometry and rasterized
triangles and stuff like that.
>>Jeff Sharkey: That's a great question.
So are -- you're talking about like taking
an input of like something to draw and then
outputting pixels, like rendering?
>>> Right.
>>Jeff Sharkey: That's a great question.
I don't know the answer offhand.
Catch us afterwards.
There's somebody here that probably has the
answer.
Yeah?
>>> If you have a multipass algorithm and
you're splitting up the work across several
cores, how do you do synchronous --
>>Jeff Sharkey: Yeah, so you're talking about
like you may have multiple stages of an algorithm
that you want to apply to an allocation.
So the output of one allocation may be the
input to another.
One way would be to merge those algorithms
-- so it's C, you could call out to methods,
so you could call like method A, and then
method B and actually pass the data that way.
But are you saying like those -- the stages
are fully dependent, maybe just not at the
pixel level?
>>> Well, even to take your example, if you
were to -- if you have a filter so you now
have one intermediate output.
Now you want to apply something else, and
you want to access neighboring pixels so you
cannot just split the task up completely and
just combine at the final stage, you want
to have intermediate basic asynchronization.
>>Jeff Sharkey: I think I see what you're
saying.
So in that case, you could do a single for
each method where you invoke to say process
this allocation.
Internally it could process the first allocation,
it would take like the output of one and input
to the other.
As far as like helping pipeline those things,
I don't know what renderscript offers under
the hood.
I think the worst-case scenario, you could
run the for each, do an RS.finish to make
sure that that processing is done, and then
take the output allocation and pipe it into
an input of another for each.
Worst case.
Thanks.
Go ahead.
>>> You discussed, in talking about the multicore
capability of renderscript that in the future,
Google would support or the API would support
GPU.
>>Jeff Sharkey: Yeah.
>>> Is there -- what are the options right
now if you want to break up either a computation-intensive
task and be parallelized or, you know, 3-D
rendering or something and utilize the GPUs?
>>Jeff Sharkey: So at the moment, right, so
renderscript, the implementations that are
shipping today, just use the CPU side of things.
In the future, we're working on enabling it
on GPUs, but there's nothing that splits up
that work today in that way.
I've seen it --
>>> Is there any other mechanism?
>>Jeff Sharkey: Not that I know of.
Let's sync up afterwards.
>>> Thank you.
>>Jeff Sharkey: Yeah.
Yeah, go ahead.
>>> What is -- given that you break the code
into bit code, what's the difference between
the renderscript engine and Dalvik, why couldn't
this have been Java, for example, if we were
making -- we have bit code, byte code and
it's being chewed on beforehand, why isn't
this part of Dalvik, why is it different?
>>Jeff Sharkey: So renderscript was designed
-- it's designed mostly for the compute-intensive
side of things.
So it's very -- it's specific in nature, it's
designed to like crunch a lot of number -- like
number-crunching.
Dalvik is very general purpose.
So it's maybe a design goal that may be different.
>>> Cool, thanks.
>>Jeff Sharkey: Yeah.
All right.
Looks like we don't have any other questions.
All right, thanks, everyone, for your time
today.
[ Applause ]